Speaker 1: I'm going to play a video clip for
you today, which is really a great example of
reporters doing what they're supposed to do, which
is when you ask a question and it's not answered,
you ask it again. And if you're not able to ask
it again, your colleague asks it again. This,
you've got to see this. One of the things that
was done in Arizona after the 2020 election
was that an alternative slate of electors
signed a document saying that they were
the electors from Arizona. Now you might remember
Joe Biden won Arizona. And so Arizona Senate
Democratic electors to Washington, D.C.,
to say Arizona casts our electoral votes
in favor of Joe Biden. Nothing controversial
there. We now have uncovered fake state documents
falsely declaring that Donald Trump won the
2020 election. On Tuesday, Rachel Maddow shared
five fake certificates of ascertainment sent to
the National Archives in an ill conceived plot
to make it seem as if Trump had won. One of the
Republican lawmakers who signed that fake document
is State Representative Jake Hoffman. Jake Hoffman
was confronted by a number of reporters and asked,
Why did you sign a fake declaration? It's bogus.
Joe Biden won. What? Why would you sign that?
Jake Hoffman seems to realize he may be in legal
hot water here. He tries to avoid answering the
questions. He's asked them again and then look at
how he simply implodes and says he doesn't know
how he even ended up in a position to sign
it. This is unbelievable. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: When Bram wants to ask
a real question, I'm happy to have
a conversation with him. Thank you. So.
Unidentified: I think what you want is a
couple of things that they on their cellphones.
Speaker 1: OK, so the question was how did you
end up being in the position of being an elector,
given you're a Republican? Joe Biden won. OK? So
here we go. Let's see what he says.
Speaker 2: I'm asking you that
question. You wonder, what authority did you find
yourself as a woman? So in unprecedented times,
unprecedented action is occurred. There is no
case law. There's no precedent that exists as
to whether or not a an election that is
currently being litigated in the courts
Speaker 1: has new standing. Now understand that
everything he just said is B.S.. The Arizona
election results were by definition, not being
litigated in the courts when they tried to send
an alternate slate of Republican electors
in January. There had been legal challenges
between the election and the certification of the
election, which happened in November and December,
respectively. At the time that it was certified,
it's no longer being litigated in court just
because you submit something and keep submitting,
submitting, submitting stuff to a court
saying you believe it should be disputed doesn't
mean it's being litigated. Everything he's saying
is untrue. Now, when he says there's no
precedent, there's no reason to believe
that you would be able to send an alternate slate
of electors just for the hell of it because you
keep filing disputes and disputes in court. The
election had been, yes, disputed between November
and December. Certified. And at that point,
it's no longer in dispute. Legally speaking,
so what he's saying is completely bogus.
But watch how much crazier it gets.
Speaker 2: Which is why we felt it appropriate
to provide Congress and the vice president with
dueling opinions. Did you have direction from
anybody in doing this? Was it you 11 yourself
to doing this, or did someone give you advice?
Speaker 1: So this is a great question. Did the
11 of you who said we are the electors rather than
the actual electors? Did you guys do this yourself
or did someone tell you to do it?
Speaker 2: The manner in which you can do it?
So I'm simply I was one of the electors. Right,
right. I'm not in charge of the electors. So
how did you hear it? You wouldn't
withdrew here. You would need to ask
the party chairman, how did you hear about
the plan, which is going to be something
that you would need to ask the party?
Speaker 1: This is so unbelievable.
He's just being asked. OK.
You're one of 11. Who told you,
Hey, we're going to do this.
We're going to do this document.
How did how did the plan come together?
Speaker 2: Because you're the you're the
person who received the call. You showed up,
right? How did you know to show up that day?
So as I said, you can go ahead and ask the
party chair just to ask her how you got a phone
call the person you're welcome to talk to them
about. Do you not know how you arrived at a place?
Thank you. I appreciate it. You really not
know how you got a call. Have a great one.
The other question I was hoping to shoot
Speaker 1: this is just this is really,
really well-done. Understand what he's
saying. It's it's sort of like if I say,
Hey, when I used to be on a dodgeball team,
right, intramural dodgeball team or whatever,
you're here playing right and you have teammates.
Yes. OK. How did you know to come here today?
You get you got to ask somebody else. No, but
I mean, like, is there a schedule? How did you
because you want to play dodgeball and
you think playing dodgeball is good? But
how did you know to be here at six today? Like was
is that part of a league or oh, no, no, no, no. It
doesn't make any sense, and this guy realizes
that he's in legal hot water. Reporters should
be doing this in the press briefing room when
one answer gets blown off. You have to. The next
person has just got to ask the same question.
Same question, same question. Now, is it too
much to expect prosecution here here? Because what
they've done is very simple. What they did here is
extraordinarily serious. Understand that they sent
a document representing that they are the electors
when they are not the electors. Joe Biden won
Arizona this. There are a number of different
possible crimes here, and I'm not even going to
list them because it's all still very early and
lawyers are sort of in the speculative phase. But
can we expect prosecution here? I don't know the
answer to that. I fear that the answer is no,
but really good job done by those reporters.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter and let
me know what you make of it. Our program depends
on the support of our viewers and listeners. You
can make a contribution and get tons of extras
while doing it by getting a membership at Join
Packman dot com. We do an extra show every day
for our members, called the bonus show. You
can sign up at join Packman dot com. Yes,
we are still banned from Facebook monetization.
Five or six different people are lobbying on our
behalf, but we are as of now, four days into a
90 day monetization ban. So you can sign up at
Join Pacman dot com with the coupon code EFF.
Facebook Quite quite, quite quite a coupon code